I haven't been in Singapore for even a
whole day so I'm like that's trying to
stay with your dreamy and sleepy and
everything seems with an amazing of the
center so if something I'm saying sounds
weird it's my current jet lag state so
when I come back to learn that you
should ask me the same question and it
would make more sense so that's it yeah
so I'm self-analysis jason said I worked
for Mozilla I am in the London office so
that means right now is like three or
four a.m. my time and I'm I just been
the devil team I just moved to the
Firefox of those same because I wanted
to make the tools better so I'm now an
interview manager there and I'm not
Spanish as you can say i'm not very like
sending English very English so because
English is not my first language I do
think that native speakers don't which
is wonder about the language so when I
feel expressions like it's raining cats
and dogs I'm like what so I went to the
internet and i searched what that means
and it brings you back to an old time
where the streets were full of provision
dead animals and when it rained it
rained so hard that it would just carry
away all the dead animals so that's what
it means that when it's raining cats and
dogs and another expression that has
been interesting to me lately it's been
going against the grain and so again I
wish I'd what does this actually mean
and the dictionary says that is contrary
to natural inclination of feeling of
someone or something it goes against the
grain to tell outright lies from the
fact that food is easy to cut along the
lane the line of the grain and I am a
software developer in session r idea how
you cut wood so I went to the internet
again and it's told me that it was easy
to cut along the grain and across the
grain I still didn't know what did mean
because you know like even Buddha would
use nowadays is fake so I'm like I don't
know but the internet is amazing it gave
me a diagram so it shows you what along
close the crime mins so it was like oh
yeah those timber people like when they
go with the arcs if they go with the
arcs across this line is very easy you
get your visit up they are cutting a
tree that in that direction but you
never see them cut on the other action
you see them but it takes them longer
it's not like one clean cut so the oil
interesting fact the internet told me is
that the bull is also stronger along the
grain so if you give a caretaker one of
those plans the first one is going to be
harder to kind of like just slicing just
one hit the second one which you can't
really see very well but it's like cut
in the other direction so this is going
to break you can see that this is like
total set out like if a kratika can cut
that you know that it's not a very good
caretaker so my car was very interesting
another thing that the internet show me
is an a demo of days with the spaghetti
so you can see this is blood grain
fibers and you can see that this is the
effect that you will get when you cut
with an axe along the direction of the
grain so the other final call saying
that the internet tell me about both and
grains is that you also need to keep
this thing in mind when you apply polish
or you get these scratches which are
awful this is what happens when you can
affect some against the direction of the
grain sound like this is so cool like
the crane is intrinsic to the balls so
if you do things properly you can like
very nice finish product they are really
nice to look at your like oh this is
like good artisanal crafty work but if
you don't do that if you just ignore the
fact that bull has grain you get things
that Flint's a scratch or brittle they
break and you're like interesting I was
like like this I'm a screen like yeah
this sounds familiar this is just like
more than web development we're just
ignoring the grain we're just doing
whatever we think it's cool and then
everything breaks and it's like I don't
know what you did here and all the talks
today have been mentioned a like prison
use bootstrap please don't do these
please don't break the browser's I'm
like this is very good because you like
telling things I'm really caring about
so what's the web natural direction and
I'm going to be captain obvious but hTML
free content is a representation and
generous giver functionality you would
think that people would know the things
nowadays but no so when you build with
these principles in mind you're cutting
along the green which is the good thing
and you're playing to the website
strengths I would go into more detail
but that's basically what I want to like
hint I can stress today even if this is
just a CSS conference CSS is so
connected to everything you can't just
take one thing and ignore the rest so
you build websites this way they're
delightful to use because you know the
browser can do the browser job and also
still there also job so let the browser
do what I can do like you know like
stretch things around zoom in zoom out
the kind of things use keyboards that
kind of things that process let you do
when you don't mess with the browser and
then you can just fill the gaps for
extra things that the president doesn't
know yet and maybe it will do the
feature if enough also ask the browser
vendors to do that so some developers
will against the web natural direction
they say i want to have full control but
what happens is like they interfere with
the browser and you end up with those
things like the little cross as Chris
was mentioning where you kind of press
ask you cannot press the cross you kind
of tap away because there is no normal
interface like nothing works as a
respect so that's very frustrating to
use or do you go for presale tix are
perfect device this is bad but it's even
worse and phones when you have an
android phone and you get off an iphone
do i because they want to make things
native or when you have an iphone and
you get material design and you're like
I don't know what this is anymore this
is all very strange so this is the
uncanny valley of UI design or you get
this long time for requests to render
where you like waiting and waiting I can
fill this a lot because I used roaming a
lot
when I'm traveling alone and when you're
and roaming I pani your data goes
through your server in your country so
it takes long so you're like waiting and
waiting I eventually just give up
especially when you don't get any render
at all when something breaks on the
meantime there is a timeout nothing
renders and you're like okay fine I just
wanted to see the many on your website
but now i'm not going to your restaurant
so they all think that but developer
store is ignoring aspects that exist in
the platform it's like ignoring the
grain they assume that there is no
network like things magically come to
your device they also know that the
browser raises many of the things they
are implementing and they also ignore
all the uses like I really like the top
from craves like make things work with
universal design it's a bit like the
kind of things I'm worried about it's
like they're like oh were crying my
computer with my super accurate mobility
but you try to give them to other people
and you can't they can't use the
products they're like I this is this
menu this rule over men is too far for
me I can't focus and it can make people
cry it's really they also know that the
web environment is unpredictable and
it's unknown it's not just about people
using strange forms of people using
things on 3g and 40 or whatever it's all
about people installing plugins on their
browsers and also about people using
websites with things like assistive
technology stuff like screen readers or
like even real reader mode is a version
of assistive technology you can have so
many things in the environment that you
kind of read trusted javascript your
road is a javascript is going to be
executed so if you expect that your
whole app is going to work because you
assume this kind of like idea of pure
JavaScript environment you're going to
like set fall for a disaster so what
happens is the day to implement things
are exist battling and then they create
junk accessibility things that cannot be
used or things are just
drain battery and it's like all terrible
and Bob and it makes me so sad and so
upset at the same time and this is all
because we want to make an appt and now
so the private days is that the
developers of this kind of apps I like I
really hate web development this is so
awful and terrible they go to medium and
blood a post about how terrible web
government is nowadays and it's like so
awful and then people hate using these
kind of things because they are so
against users their aunt Alice's
traveling here too I am up fold at this
I have have bosses insisting had to be
picture-perfect and things like that I'm
like you know the web is not about pics
a favor and keep it be like no it has to
be perfect so yeah we've been there it's
it's something that happens but the
thing that really makes me really upset
this one I might you sir because I'm
like you could have done it the other
way and you still chose to do it this or
a terrible way so I'm here more as a
user than as a developer so you would
not think that this is a solution but
there is a solution and it's making
watches not making apps and I'm just
like again captain obvious the things
that the websites like building website
has this almost 30 years old of
experience behind so if you cannot be
some breakfast so a framework if you
come up with a framework it's not going
to have those 30 years of experience and
standards and consensus and discussions
so your framework is not going to last
for longer than the website and I
properly build website is going to last
longer than any type of Griffin would
you could possibly build so for example
I want to show you something really cool
which is the first website I can still
open with my current browser can you
imagine opening nobody's browsers like
nobody's websites with current with
these first browser it will be
impossible candle so it's it's really
some food for thought so how do we do
this thing because I'm just like being
angry here so again captain obvious you
need to start by architect in your
content and design in your content so
what is what your users need like you
can't start saying we're going to use
this framework that's not how you start
their content you need to start thinking
about what do they use this name do they
need a single bay web page up maybe they
just need if it's a restaurant sample
many opening times booking form
something like that like that that's the
kind of question we should be asking
yourself do I need to load a full
templating engine to render a blog or
maybe you could just friended I on your
server and cash it forever so you don't
waste energy in the world the kind of
ideas is what I'm going through etc so
once you know what you want to actually
mean I mean this is I'm just saying
about progressive and his men but once
you know what you want to build you just
use it smell and turns out that age to
my right self has lots of features cool
things the advanced browsers are going
to be nicer to the users but older
browsers will be just functional so they
don't know as much suggest ignore
whatever they don't know about so for
example if you have an anchor and you
say H ref tell lalalala a phone number
if a browser knows about that when you
click on the phone number it will say I
mean if the presonus about and your rind
is in a phone they would be like that
you want to call this number and this is
just extending something that the webmin
readers which is showing you links if
you use pattern in form inputs you can
have regular expression validation built
in the forms you don't need to pull a
library to do this thing if you use
input time number and you use this thing
in a device like a phone as well which
is like cumbersome to type numbers and
things which is a very small screen it
will bring a special dial kind of like
styling keyboards so you make things
easy for your users in the proper
context so you're kind of like given the
browser hints as to what kind of content
it is and the browser or the user agent
is going to be like okay I'm going
to help you do these things and that
works when you use XML correctly if you
just use diffs and sponge and you don't
markup things properly the browser has
no clue of what you want to do so it's
not going to help you and then CSS this
is what we're here for we need to go
bottom up a game like it was very cool
that Rachel also explained this thing
like you need to start with the most
basic browser and I would like to say
that every router can be a basic browser
at some point when you don't get all the
sites loaded or when something kind of a
mrs. out the load it can become a basic
browser so an even when sometimes you
get like a mobile website URL sent to
you that's the computer and there is no
detection or whatsoever you end up with
a basic kind of like version of the
website so I want to still get proper
content so you need to start here and
make sure he did say in default for
those basic browsers like many people
just specify the gradient but they don't
specify the base background so when you
try to use some websites with browsers
like opera mini that strip out the
complicated CSS properties if you didn't
specify the background and the gradient
says this is a dark background and the
text is like black you can took it like
black over black which is not exactly
what you wanted to do so you you're like
making things difficult for yourself you
didn't just a cascade properly am also
please don't use proprietary prefixes
but if you really need to use
preprocessor so you make sure that you
don't miss out on any perfect and again
these supports if that's something that
you have to learn today please your
support so you don't send things to
process that don't understand them and
always be learning like the cool thing
of CSS is that they seen that is always
the same more or less it's not changing
a lot so new things that you learn you
can use you don't need to forget the
things if you're free a new and also if
you understand CSS it's going to be like
great because you are not going to just
like copy things from the internet it's
going to be really good because then you
can buy things your own so like I guess
rewatching Rachel's talk and the count
it's going to be really really cool
because you can like remember the things
that she's been suggesting and like
learning really how things like the new
things work and just like and learn the
new things they all things that we used
to use and this is my special for you we
part of ESS ESS developer like your real
developer no don't tell don't let people
tell you you might have really available
because you're just writing JavaScript
like well you know what India is good
you are a real developer and writing
good CSS is really available if you
write good size you can have with so
many lines of Battier you have a script
code and it's going to be all so fast
and more performant because the browser
is going to like be like Oh CSS I know
how to the listing and I'm going to be
hard we're accelerating days and i'm
going to use less energy so that's going
to be better for mobile users which
happen to be a lot of people so feel
proud to be CSS developers you aren't
great so then when you are like oh yes
some CSS developer when you get to
javascript please be it really wise
again the way with great power comes
great responsibility Janice can break
things really badly so please don't send
things the browsers that don't know
other things so there is this polyfill
service by the FT they will make sure
that things are like properly like all
the gaps are properly pulley field and
you can also configure that so it
doesn't send the whole thing of like the
whole list of polyfills this is my
personal personal advisors programmer
please use feature libraries or
frameworks like maybe you're just going
to use a fraction of all the powers not
a framework is offering you so maybe
just try to use the little thing that
you need and if you really master please
use frames with axe ability built-in not
just like I saw frame with the other day
I say oh mobile is not at the top of our
priority it's not what they said I'm
like are you from the 90s like seriously
and remember that no frames is a silver
bullet like just by choosing booster up
or react or whatever you want to use
it's not going to sort out your issues
like if your content is bound at a time
no frameworks going to fix your content
things to watch out for is at tracking
and all stuff I interface with browsers
it's very interesting to know how to
learn how two hours rendering pipeline
works and how you know like when
resources don't know they how it affects
with what the browser is doing how how
things are stopped waiting for other
things to parse and accounting and
especially if you're going to be
inserting apps and things that your boss
is going to tell you how we really need
to track this thing you need to bring
them up like every time you are then
beacon this is going to slow things down
so they need to know that when they
don't make money with the website that
is a reason behind that so if you could
measure things if you have data you can
argue with them every time we add this
thing we have this drop in sales or
whatever so you need data to be able to
remove the crabs later and also watch
out for content that we just no display
if javascript breaks like for example if
all your content requires loading a big
chunk of JavaScript and parsing the
thing it just won't display in basic
browsers so my the crux of this is if
you really want to replace something a
browser is doing you better know what
you're doing because honestly browsers
are a complicated piece of machinery so
the thing is that when you're like young
and ambitious you think you can do
better but often that's not the case so
the reason the browser is a big thing is
because there is a reason for that so
important this is not like a server-side
conference but this is important as well
and it's like it's not sexy or cool or
whatever and I hate sexy applied to
technology but service is important
because in basic browsers and in like
all in like all new phones server-side
rendering is still faster than every
possible JavaScript improved performance
whatever just giving people render HTML
and they just they can just like okay I
know how to do this thing where as
everything else that you can put in
way is going to have a very long time
for requests to render and people are
going to abandon their website so and do
you need a thing anyway react lets you
do this I mean the reason people just
react is because they can do this it's a
morphic JavaScript and serve just in PHP
which is not fashionable anymore
apparently even if it keeps doing the
job and server side validation is a
still require so if you get data from
the outside world you need to still
validate so why not do like everything
together again let me stress this server
side validation insisted required you
can't trust people from the outside you
can't trust the people of range of
JavaScript front side up and not getting
junk injected because you know a lot of
viruses that can take over browsers and
some crap to people through the browser
even if they are affiliated and things
like that so don't trust front end all
the time and also in this is very funny
but this it's very easy to get gains
from this from checking server
configuration for caching and just also
things like enabling compression I just
work in a place that were said we were
serving like this was before iphone
existed and just enabling jzip made us
like super fast like we save so much in
bad ways and and I said that it was
before the iPhone because my boss have
one of those Nokia's that were super
advanced back in the time and he was
like now I can open this website on the
phone which I couldn't do before because
it was it was just timing out but with
jay-z been able it was short enough that
he could just get the whole thing so
it's funny is like just simple easy
things you can do and then you get
really good gains I'm also related to
faster transmissions consider HTTP two
is a talk about this later and then you
require HTTPS 482 DP 2 and also for
privacy sensitive aph like service
workers on a la la which I'm really
briefly mention later to diagnose you
can use developer tools
the the network panel and you can see
the Heather's have been returned when I
don't know what the crew won but the
fire festival to have something where
you can see how long it takes how much
data you get on the first on the second
request so you can see if things are
being cut properly and of course the web
page test and this is how I know imagine
me like a haven't really sled Matt
imagine if it's hard but the truth is
I'm writing software is hard no one told
you this was like funny what do you is
funny but it's her um but at least we'd
have to build the browser first in
theory that would be very hard and and
the thing again browsers are amazing we
have a Helen in turn this this summer
and he was implementing a feature in
several he was like service a browser i
feels like it's amazing like he was just
implementing double-click but just like
we get this kind of like interactions
that we don't even think about what
process do so many things for you really
and with Pleakley ignore them for some
reason and the list of features is just
growing and growing like all the cool
CSS features have been discussing today
like all the ligatures of the grill on
flex layout we can do so many great
things and we can be so innovative on
the web and have all this freedom like
when i started to web development we
have to take images of custom phones and
slice them and i like them in a table
and use n & mm BSP elements and take
that I we don't need to do any that
anymore you can be really semantics and
very clear on what we mean this is great
we have things like offline support so
you can turn any website and I think
that works offline so you don't need to
suffer with like roaming and things just
your the directions to your hotel are
already in your phone sort of school you
can engage people with push
notifications with service workers as
well you can even install the app if you
really are very engaged with this
website and with this website because
all this is built on top of a website so
what that means is because the way of
brands
work if they understand these things
they are going to offer this option to
you if they don't they are still a
website and they still work so when I
hear people saying I'm just not going to
support Safari safaris in Hawaii I'm
like are you crazy like what about all
the iphones and like oh they do super
service workers back but but that
doesn't mean that you have to make your
appt up dependent on just service
workers like you can still have a
website it just won't work offline
because you know Safari but the rest
should work so that's that's the thing I
want to like converted a like if you
build a website you can add more
features on top and it's not like an all
of nothing like it is with apps like if
I make an Android app it's either you
have an android phone or you don't have
it you can use this up or if then I
phone comes with a new version of a kind
of hybrid between hi phone and what's
the other thing ipad and then you have
to build a version of the app for Daniel
saying that's ridiculous but with a
website to just get one thing that works
everywhere and it's like it's totally
mind-blowing and I don't understand how
people are so keen on using steel apps
when you have all these great things so
it's exciting times the via web
developer and the thing again is that we
can reach so many people like I don't
even know how many people in on earth
but there is so many people that already
connected to the Internet and the
millions of a common new internet users
they are actually not using iPads they
are not using iPhones and they are using
and reader they are using like I mean
those fancy androids there is like cheap
android phones and they have like small
data plans and they don't want to
install app they just want to have their
photos and you know like access websites
because it just don't have a space
they're really cheap phones so I'm the
only important thing is that the process
they are using you haven't even heard
them before because they're like totally
custom things that the couriers are
building and things like like UC browser
which I've never do this because
a bad developer so that's it whole thing
like if you build in a way that your
prepare for the unknown you are safe if
you're trying to just use things that
you control that you're familiar with
your like set for failure and i say i
work at mozilla we love the web so we're
researching exploring the feature of the
web one of the things we're working on
is server which is a new browser it's
parallel say from performant as a new
browser engine is Britain in rust the
holidays because it's written in rust
it's a very safe language so if there is
a crash which is prayer user data should
not be put in the insurance so people
cannot steal your back credentials and
things like that and the other cool
aspect of rest is that is very parallel
by default so we are trying to make sure
that we are using all the of the
hardware in mobile browsers which means
that so mobile browsers have more course
but each course is lower so normal kind
of like traditional browsers are
designed for mono Corps maybe a graphics
card and the problem is that that's not
very efficient in mobile browsers so
with several we're trying to build a new
thing from the ground up that uses all
the course in phones and it's way more
efficient because you can use things in
parallel so we can do things like web
render which is a new CSS engine that
makes things like which for this you can
use left and you can just stop and there
is no performance issue with that it's
amazing you don't need to be thinking
about oh I need to use translate instead
of left because left is not going to be
fast enough so with web render you can
ignore the thing and the other good
thing we're doing is we're taking things
from said well I'm moving them into
Firefox so we can have like the feature
in the present so we're probably
starting with some parts of the URL
parsing which is a huge factor for
attacks like there are many good level
never abilities that are due to during
parsing so we're taking things like that
web render is possibly one of the things
that is coming to the Firefox soon
because obviously we want to make CSS as
fast as possible so you and even need to
one there
is going to be bad or slow we want
people to just bright normal CSS is
having to think about what the browser
has to do to render this thing is it
going to be bad as you can to be slow
and more things that don't make any
sense in this conference because this is
a purely JavaScript sub thanks and I'll
be around probably having more coffee
because I'm like starting to feel
strange I think I've been really fast
but not sure time is very elastic from
me right now all right thank you sort of
that it's a very great talk about making
websites and not applications and just
reminding all of us not to ignore all
the different things that we have in our
browsers and skip to the app and feel
that it's all the best thing out the
process still the best and by the way
how many CSS developers here give me a
raise of your hands CSS FTW all right
I'm before any questions for some of
that I shall take the money and run the
round if you have any questions come on
come on all right I see someone's
scratching ahead all right all right so
if there are no questions I'll have one
question to up oh okay all right there's
so many things in browsers nowadays like
just like so much force taking right now
so how do you even begin learning of
this stuff like what would be a proper
roadmap for someone who is new to the
web different browsers how will you
recommend for us to learn all the stuff
out there is a very good question and I
would like to know how to answer the
property we have the Mozilla developer
Network which is the documentation site
we are trying to write guides for
developers who are new because most of
the content they can find em
how to write xml is from the 90s or the
2000s and it's like it doesn't really
have good practices anymore so we're
trying to write new guides which are
more like more than worth development I
think someone told me that code Academy
was really great for them but my problem
is that i started doing web development
in 1996 so I'm like I know it's natural
to me so yeah maybe I should just speak
to more beginners so I can understand
that paint better but yeah we're trying
in developer mozilla org she'll have
content for beginners
you